disposition cher Peaks atterrissant sur le
problème Roger quand nous vaincrons juste
après 70 le problème excité tu veux
remonter l'ouest c'est juste un battement l'
héliport ici à 500 head shop qui
livre a tiré le gars sur les plaignants
sur le pont Tappan Zee du centre-ville
copie  monsieur, merci de prendre adulte ce
parc de batteries jusqu'à nous, je veux que mes
hôtels du centre-ville soient autour des portes de la batterie,
je vous ai sur ma gauche,
je vais descendre un peu, disons 500
comment nous le regardons, nous vous appelons je ne  Je ne
sais pas s'il est possible de se mettre du côté
du pont et de Manhattan à l'arrière de
quel pont un cassé est-il sûr que
vous pouvez vous positionner pour que nous puissions
obtenir que je vous montrerai que c'est beaucoup
mieux au lever du soleil mais c'est au coucher du soleil
qu'il a besoin  d'entre nous, c'est à l'époque
où j'étais très minutieux de
voir cette centrale électrique là-bas ouais nous
franchissons cette frontière de poignée de centrale électrique,
vous pourriez obtenir cette centrale électrique juste ouais
super copains dans votre groupe au-dessus d'eux au
centre-ville c'est l'un d'un coup du matin mais
ouais Porter  le point a un Silpat j'aime ça
je suis à peine moi-même prêt
à sentir BEC,
espérons-le, aller vers le sud pour obtenir ma tour
les coussinets sous vous à 800 $
vous voulez vous faire battre sur le pont est
très peu tout va amener les
voitures là-bas le  pont ouais avez-vous
aimé zoomer ouais comme ça
Les gens de l'hôtel en haut arrivent en
ce moment
merci les
deux Peters deviennent gay pour ce 1.1 facile
nous sortons bien vous voyez cet
hélicoptère là-bas qui est assez bas
il n'y a pas de suce juste à côté  les 300
kilomètres hé tu veux regarder du
côté ouest au côté est au côté ouest à
travers les bâtiments ouais
qu'est-ce que ça fait ouais
dans un cercle et un contre le nord sur l'
East River ici je pense et tu peux
continuer comme ça que tu  sachez en
lancer six autres jusqu'à ce que Steven
3:09 fasse comme tous les sacs de pot HubSpot
par ici, comment les
gars ont dû faire le tour de mademoiselle
Loretta hein quand vous voulez prendre cette
photo, les gens que je devrais avoir un bateau de merde
était  va etre  en dessous ouais c'est ça
mettre ce pied à travers le Williamsburg
qu'est-ce qui te manquera des poids à la naissance
comme chez l'homme Chrysler c'est génial
oh ouais ouais [ __ ] l'a si chaud
oh il y a un hélicoptère là-dedans ouais
New York s'il vous plaît allez-y même si
c'est juste  au nord, ce sera vraiment
ce sera quelques rues une fois que nous serons au nord
de l'ONU Je crois que nous pouvons regarder directement
de l'East River dans la rivière Hudson
si vous pouvez faire l'oiseau
parce que notre plus proche est mal
éclairé  tu veux grimper autour de ça ouais aller de l'avant
j'ai donc zéro à dix sans
disparaître il est l'héliport de la 34e rue
8,00 $ squawk faire deux un sept un deux
requête zéro deux un sept comme au-
dessus de la station McCain faire du basket
la boucle de fitness
J'allais suggérer que  à la tête
le bouton de commande
si j'y retourne également
vous êtes comme un golfeur j'ai contacté que
le lien est en direction du nord 15 aller chercher
s'il vous plaît apporter un contact et pousser pour le
faire comme l'hélicoptère une fois que vous avez
cela  Va te faire [ __ ] en retournant à l'
Empire
ouais j'aimerais faire une boucle autour de
toi juste au-dessus de toi effacer nos pensées payez le
trafic sur l'Empire maintenant dirigez-vous
vers le sud du parc en
descendant vers l'Empire State hors des deux mm
séjour  sur les cibles plus sympa
tu fais une autre pizza circulaire oh j'ai
oublié l'épave d'une voiture demain du
départ multiversal d'Hudson les gars regarde
mon poignet si tu ne peux pas fusilli Ligurie
bonsoir j'étais là-haut j'ai capté
mon écho est tout de 1.5  ou ou charlie
comme je suis pour un hélicoptère donc 100 maintenant st.
Lazare mm ci-dessous d'accord je crois donc d'
accord je dirai
qu'ils peuvent faire de la lumière dehors s'il vous plaît Peter
où vous voulez aller d'ici
montons un peu bien nous cherchons à
chercher le trou un bon